and jordan montgomery's ready to go his
warm-up tosses are done
he's about to begin his 10th start of
the season right there and the numbers
progressively have gotten a lot better
and the scatter report we talked about
that career night that's seven shutout
innings no walks 11 k's
the thrill of the chase 34 34 of his
pitches that are outside the strike zone
are chased by hitters that's the third
highest rate behind josh fleming and
dylan bundy well two down and here is
the guy who's been their best hitter
vladimir guerrero jr a ground ball to
first lemayo will take it himself to the
bag
montgomery has a one two three boy
robbie ray what a turnaround he has had
as far as throwing strikes and not
giving up too many walks he had six
walks in his second start of the season
at kansas city against the royals and
he's only walked one batter since
and last time out he completed seven
innings for the first time since
june of 2019 against the dodgers he went
seven innings allowed one run on five
hits and struck out seven here's ashelah
with first and second in one man out hit
in the air to deep left field that ball
is going to be over the head of gorial
going all the way to the wall
one round scores here comes judge here
comes the throw and he is out at only
great relay throw got judge at home
played it's an rbi double for arshella
and the yankees take a one-nothing lead
perfect relay by the blue jays to get
judged but the yankees take a
one-nothing lead on the rbi double by
urchella see aaron judges reed on this
play i mean it's a line drive wasn't
sure if he's going to catch it or not
he's got to make sure a slight
hesitation right there
very aggressive move
from mindy the third base coach here all
the way down
took a perfect throw to get him maybe
that hesitation a little bit davis is
eight for 52 with a homer in three rbis
here comes the 3-2 to davis
and it's line to third going to be a
double play michelle throws to first
and yes it's a double play they did
everything right
they smelled scary
they sent espinal
and davis did his job he had a line
drive unfortunately hit it right under
shella so the double play goes 5-3 or i
said well this is a tough tough duo to
double up unless you do that first and
second two down one nothing yankees top
of the third bo bushed wants to get him
right now and a swing and a high fly
ball
left center field
[Applause]
he did get him right now
a breaking ball over the heart of the
plate and boba shed homers for the
second game in a row here in the
doubleheader and the blue jays take the
lead i tell you what he hit that ball
like aaron judge hits home runs and he
is just a average guy but he generates a
lot of bad speed and he was looking for
that breaking ball and boy did he hammer
it and he knew it got all of it
and when you hit him in yankee stadium
to the big part of the field and you can
stand there at home plate admire them
you hit it hard well here's judge who
walked his first time he is the tying
run as he stands in swung on and hit in
the air to center field that ball is
high it is far it is gone
monument park
a judging blast
aaron judge ties the game with a
tremendous home run to monument park all
rise
here comes the judge well you said it he
was trying to be careful with him it
never works unless you just go ahead and
walk him fastball he had to come in and
he knew immediately he tried to get it
on the outside part of the plate he
missed that's what happened he missed it
was right over the middle of the plate
and he just clocked that you saw davis
going back sort of sauntering back he
knew there was no way he was going to
catch up to that one here's gary sanchez
he had a fly ball to left his first time
high drive there it goes
[Applause]
see ya
a long home run for sanchez
4-3 yankees
gary sanchez just had a line drive into
the visitors bullpen in left center
field
to give the yankees a lead
oh that gary is scary
he homers and the yankees lead it 4-3
you know and isn't that what happens
he's going fastball fastball fastball he
was getting so frustrated by sanchez um
following those off that he threw him
that slider at 90 miles an hour it sped
up gary's bat and he just clocked it
jonathan lawaziga his 21st game of the
year
inherits a runner on first base
and facing the dangerous bo buchet
slider strike three what a break and you
could see that break with the naked eye
that's a heck of the pitch now a base
hit could pretty much give the yankees
an ample lead swung on and driven to
deep right center field
back is
tayasaka on the warning track makes the
catch wade tags and scores
on to third goes taurus is a sac fly and
an rbi for judge
and the yankees have a 5-3 lead
you know when judge swung
i thought the ball had a chance like i
guess he got it maybe
off the end of the bat or so anyway
hernandez caught it on the very edge of
the track in right field you know what
i'm just looking at aaron judge's face
he knew he knew that he didn't get it
exactly
he's a little out in front of it so
guerrero aboard and te oscar hernandez
is the batter can they turn two
there's one
there's two a four four three double
play heads up by wade
tyler wade instead of funneling the
second
stopped and tagged the runner going to
first and second then how to fire it to
first
and so the yankees their specialty they
turn double plays baby do they turn
double plays
so rowdy
teles
pinch hitting for espionage
tying runs are on base yankees lead 5-3
are in the sixth inning
grouted weekly to third o'shella throws
to first in time one pitch one out
to end the sixth inning let's now have a
two-run lead to protect in the final
inning chad green comes on no sign of
chapman and the pitch is hit on the
ground ashore backhanded by taurus
throws to first perfectly one away
without a base runner they have no
chance they got a base runner they got a
chance now reece mcguire the left-hand
hitter
right to wade in short right field
one out away from splitting this
doubleheader salvaging the final game of
a three-game set swung on and hit high
in the air to left field they should do
it gardner is underneath gardner makes
the catch ball game over yankees win
[Applause]
yankees win